les u20 et dans l'anarchie qui est mise
à et dans quel contexte 400 personnes du
sud du nord de l'est de l'ouest
les pertes des fermiers exempts les
personnes du secteur privé laquelle
initial membres de l'organisation de
développement
tous ont travaillé sur quand l'apport
sur l'agriculture va offrir détaillé et
juste quatre ans de travail
quatorze personnes rapport qui est
publié en 2008 et qui allie terrain
inès ezio va l'argent et quel business
le business de l'agriculture
conventionnelle des anciennes le
logiciel de cette révolution verte à
calais c'est en compte aurait inventé
mais dit elle nous a ramenés quel degré
résiste des soutes beaucoup de problèmes
en question est pourquoi ce qu'on a fait
ce rapport
parce que on a dans le monde on lui
envoie des 2 800 millions de personnes
il ne mange pas mal enfin nous avons
quand même à peu près 2000 personnes qui
vivent en dessous du seuil bourg aux
minimes ans qui vivent avec moins de 1
200 jours
c'est clair que dans certains pays en
dollars c'était pas mal mais certains
n'ont pas assez pour avoir une vie
décente
alors d'un compromis notamment pour lui
boudreau et on reproduit vous trop
politiquement correct on perd en révolte
elle devient un ensemble de ce qui est
produit dans les pays en développement
parce que là par les technologies
vous verrez toutes ces terres et
d'enlever développés on jette même après
qu'on ait acheté elles deux 30% en temps
de se lier et sa chaîne de magasins en
tout d'arriver à avoir développé un
industriel
la canicule est route est une gaspillage
le gag de 50 bossa de blainville alors
en plus au bon niveau global
je vous ai dit il ya des années 800
millions de français mangeaient on avait
un milliard et demi de personnes qui
sont obèses
on a plus de 300 millions de personnes
qui ont eu lieu type 2 qui est réduit
par une mauvaise alimentation et ça
c'est partout dans le monde les obèses
ils sont partout sénac de legnano le
diabète
10h02 odile de doug un tous ces deux
véhicules ont pour être jolie d'hambourg
est aujourd'hui à nourrir quelque 14
milliards de personnes listons produits
4600 calories par jour par personne
digne au global donc on peut dire on ne
présente plus en principe on a besoin de
moins de qualité dans différents
endroits
c'est pas aux américains aux européens
de nourrir le monde
chaque communauté chaque région doit
vraiment se nourrit elle même aussi bien
que possible superbe c'est la bourse
après différents ou dubaï
mais disons parasites dans le monde on
pourrait faire mieux mais c'est un
milieu industriel à outrance c'est
l'industrie que c'est d'une agriculture
il ou détruits qui détruit la culture
elle-même et pouvoir c'est une culture
qui produit des effets des gaz à effet
de serre et non c'était dur aussi à
déséquilibre la relation dont sud ou sud
nord alors que la légende il ne tarda ne
sont plus d'un côté de le côté des gens
qui vivent avec apparaissait donc ces
inégalités elles sont aussi ou mule par
l'unedic des industriels qui empêche les
bilans du sud de produire à des prix
raisonnables puisque ce qu'on produit en
grande quantité suspens politi
c'est savoir c'est à la nourriture c'est
toute la poubelle qui empêche moment kim
qui est substitut ligety est très bon
marché parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
suicides
un des paysans suisses sans succès ça eh
bien là c'est la même chose dans les
payant à leurs nombreux développeurs
laguiole ne paye pas mais sa maladie
grâce et puis si le gouvernement et les
paysans ouvert leur travail
enfin si les subsides cop16 vous laisse
vous mangerez mais dans le sud
non il n'y a pas les moyens de d2 les
dix ans et non qu'on a ce problème
d'égalité à et non un ce problème dit
nieddu c'est un problème c'est que tu
entendes nous avons les natures donc il
ya des chants pâturages et c'est ça le
produit la nourriture pour les humains
pour les animaux mais a connu pourquoi à
5 ou 10 par ce lieu il ya la nature des
données des services à des services des
écosystèmes
par exemple la pollinisation que vous
écoutez ab le 60% de ce couvent en
anglais de la baie alors quand une à
traiter et ce biais que vous allez me
manquer 101% dans notre assiette et 60%
que vous allez vainqueur c'est justement
ce qui va vous rendre très sain
ce sont les fruits et légumes or on
utilise ici d'abord à travers en des
trucks et se servent les services
d'écosystèmes la même chose pour les le
contrôle des ravageurs des maladies nous
montrer qu'elle est sûre tout à l'heure
alors en avant facile tout ça par le
business en ce que la nature dans cette
zone des services ça rapporte rien
personne grâce à ça ajoute de la valeur
ajoutée de taille humaine
alors gagner de l'argent avec vos mains
on repasse les saints aux machines ont
fait leurs provisions à l'intérieur
la position du visage sur les pesticides
les contrôles d éliminer le contrôle des
ravageurs et maladies
un problème nécessite la main l'équipe à
la banda les compagnies les en
produisent des quantités tant que ça
fait du business
voilà nous y voyons désormais aussi on
apprend on à des plantes
ils produisent 2 qui fixe le niveau de
la zone de l'air comme seules les
plantes non mais ça s'est compliqué un
peu barbare présente à 10 m
donc ce sont des attaques chimiques
aucun aujourd'hui donc on attend place
est un atout nous a donné a gobé voilà
donc ça sûrement la base de la
problématique aujourd'hui à
l'agriculture et de systèmes
alimentaires et c'est aussi ces
transformations de lavage de la cuisson
berck dit que j'arrêtais à cette
inculture la laideur et produit la
moitié des gaz à effet de serre que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
chaque année viennent de l'agriculture
industrielle et du système alimentaire
industriel ou agen 30 % à 50 % des aides
et vendent à la durante de production
mais aussi la transformation
alors qu'est ce qu'on doit faire on peut
remplacer ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on sait qu'on en fait ça relève
s'ébranle vers une agriculture durable
la culture bio il aux dynamiques la
permaculture il ya une sorte de annie
maury pourrait devenir neutre
c'est-à-dire ne pas produire du co2 met
en l'air et emmenée sans absorber une
fois une bille la production globale
alors si ça c'est pas une solution pour
le jeu médiatique
donnez moi une autre l'esma c'était
difficile parce que il ya des intérêts
écran privée la fff se sait dans son jeu
vous donner quelques exemples régulière
comme cette affaire du manioc et d un
million de personnes
à gauche vous avez de manioc est attaqué
par la quotidien celle du manioc
c'était bien il reste rien les gens à
pied de la gare à maputo et aussi en
amérique latine skis mal
des fois il provoque un jour c'est du
manioc les racines un don royal une
enseigne le web la différence quand même
entre hip hop et le pana alors la
solution il y un sit-in a résonné au
milieu des tentes
le problème est apparu dans le bas congo
zaïre à l'époque on aura jamais de 1929
80 la citation à rl tard il était très
grave famine dans la région et ne
viennent que doivent augmenter en cas
sont sains et le ravageur s'étaient
dispersés de cette zone où il avait
introduit par accident par l'éjection
qui n'a pas fait exprès avec cela dit
c'était attendu jusqu'à la gare de
gotein mamoudou d'autre part cet insecte
que deux insectes ils se remplissent ont
dispersé par le vent et aussi par le
fait que j'ai rien dit de manger les
eaux du manioc et comme bélier déjà
rivoire qui se voit souvent par de la
fiq
il se passe ici est venu à la maison un
des feuilles est comme ça et domaine
choisi de régler la majeure mais comme
ça ça a aidé à la distinction alors la
solution sinequa l'époque lui aussi des
récits si c'est ce qu'on s'arrêtait au
moi je le condamnerais devriez le
prochain programme du liban mais la bbc
cite moi c'est pas mon domaine comme ça
que j'ai quitté la suisse d'ailleurs
président du lobby finans on va appuyer
de la nature est ce qu on sait que la
nature est produite ces services mais il
faut les trouver
donc je suis parti me fatigue parce
qu'on savait
delacauchy venait d'une année de des
amériques entre l'équipe et le paraguay
ça c'était la naissance de l'art à
l'époque dense où ce n'est un rôti 7 km
et 10 km j'ai une poubelle
aussi dans wilde la chèque en blanc l'a
finalement un joueur baroin waziers et
aussi la bolivie est qu une fois qu'on a
trouvé la gauche ni parce qu'ils avaient
très très peu puisqu'elle était sous
votre naturel
ces travaux est une année de nombreux
trous et alors là dessus avec moi il y
avait par exemple c'est rien c'est un
parasite torino parasites
il s'attaque à la politique initiée afin
de mettre en oeuvre les dents et
l'acoustique à la facture et trois
quatre jours et dont 100 progressait
toujours plus tard vous avez nouvelle
qui va sortir de cette logique
voilà la solution
iso sont naturels en douze ans avec
exactement 20 millions de dollars
on a résolu de façon permanente un
problème et laure adler personnes
solaire il faut faire dans développement
notre panier les chiffres de ce qui se
passe donc et ça dure encore nourrir on
a fini c'est déjà un point derrière sa
revanche au cours donc la place ils
pouvaient même sa saison dissolution du
rat par la culture à part l'action du
vent il ya deux ans par exemple dans les
cultures bélanger danse danse dans ce
cas là ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on utilise nous à la nature à en
utiliser nature des gaz ou des plantes
ou s'occuper traités par ailleurs
certainement attire les insectes eric
d'autres plantes les rebooster face même
la maintenance
ils ont dit voilà t'il des odeurs de
lézat sec 1/10 n'est elle pas alors
quand on observe ce qui se passe dans
nos champs avons nous servent de ce
qu'il fasse un peu partout
du moment qu'on fonde ses solutions
naturelles nous rejouer que la zot i les
seniors ii x2 hot et aussi le système
et puisque co2 donc c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit d'une transformation des
ruptures nécessaires
les gens nous disent aussi une rupture
qui va nous sauver
ils sont pragmatiques et seulement les
bras ici l'on a foncé au rwanda français
les dix ans à conduire
j'ai plus en plus bon marché puisque les
gens pensent de littoral droite il à la
nourriture on m'a fait vous emballe
acheter mais vous transformer les
habitudes alimentaires
donc si les gens ne pensons pas leurs
habitudes et nanterre et paysans de
combat changer la façon de produire sur
julian walker en effet du maïs pas celle
de maïs on peut même faire là l'est pas
ni la révolution iraniens louis le
rachat pour un président préparant d'un
maïs des trains bondés palier l'unl côté
du mans non il faut changer des
habitudes il faut changer les falaises
de passer d'ici qui vous passez la
sauvenière peu moins de du bien de
produits laitiers et plus ce taux de
légumes et de fruits
un changement radical un changement
radical qui va vraiment aider à les dix
ans à changer leurs modes de production
ces dernières de si vous rangez d'une
façon plus diversifiée le paysan peut ou
labellisés ou avoir un système agronomie
beaucoup plus divers assystem qui est
résilient à l'encontre des changements
climatiques au niveau du bras lui il va
même en empêcher et ça aussi l' os qui
vous dire c'est que c'est pas s'étendre
a dit plus logiciels s'est passé c'est
quand magimel tout à l'heure c'est le
passé parce que c'est ça c'est ça ne
s'est pas une agriculture qui doit se
rattacher d'alban parc de sol avec
responsable donc il faut trouver la
vidéo familiale
du vendeur de lui-même homme qui va nous
aider à transformer le système ne sont
pas bons on va changer un petit peu dans
les points il faut une transformation
il faut changer le paradigme de la
production agricole ont fait aujourd'hui
pour une production hiver long et ça on
se voit ici donc c'est connu sans qu'il
soit re veut dire que le même des coups
si les petits paysans ne cotisent pas
d'une façon très dure en vous loguez
d'un une un milieu qui est très
diversifié qui tient compte des aveugles
du moment alors on veut venir il va ou
pas il n'ya pas le changement est
nécessaire parce que il ya des intérêts
prix et non empêchement des six tombes
des faits qui empêche ces
transformations et les pom girls et a
dit il ya assez où les besoins
doublement met à bas âge et aux qualités
de tout le monde